for the past million years all I've
tried to do in any writing I've done or
any creating any new characters is to
find something that I like
Marvel Comics legend Stan Lee has died
when I was originally writing these
stories nobody seemed to care and people
felt oh he's a comic book writer and I
was sort of dismissed if I go to a party
somebody would say what do you do and I
knew it was coming so I'd say oh I'm a
writer and I'd walk away Oh what are you
write and stories for kids and I'd walk
away but what stories eventually I had
to say comic books and the person would
walk away of course now it's different
now it's somebody will be talking over
there and say oh excuse me at mr. Obama
I saw Stanley walk in a better job I'm
exaggerating a little bit
Stan began his Marvel legacy when he was
just 16 years old it was known as timely
comics in those days in fact we didn't
change the name to Marvel comics until
the very early 1960s it was there his
publisher asked him to create a team of
superheroes known as the Fantastic Four
I never thought it would catch on the
way it did but it became an instant
bestseller so flushed with victory we
brought out other superheroes renowned
spider-man and the Hulk and Thor and
daredevil Iron Man The Avengers on and
on they all did well and we did them all
in this somewhat new style of giving the
heroes feet of clay and trying to make
them react the way real people would
react to a given situation and that was
it
these beloved characters and more have
been adapted on the big screen currently
as part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
where Stan often made cameo appearances
Stanley yeah nice try
it's funny the cameos I've suddenly
become known as the king of the cabbage
you get the cameo I have no competition
the only idiot who does those all the
time but they're fun I love doing them
and I'm very pleased that people asked
me to do them the whole formula if there
was one I think was to say let's assume
that somebody really could walk on walls
like spider-man or turn green and become
a monster like the Hulk that's a given
we'll accept that but accepting that
what would that person be like in the
real world if he really existed wouldn't
he still have to worry about making a
living or people distrusting him or
having acne and dandruff or his
girlfriend jilting him or what are the
real problems people would have and i
think that's what made the books popular
but it took years for the competition to
realize that I'm very happy to say
[Music]